I
nobody
I would like to begin our last panel for
this conference please be seated
I can't see back to people
ok
good evening thank you for joining or
staying for the last panel for this
conference and very honored to be to
coordinate the last panel and i'm also
very thankful for the president panel
for being so helpful to situate the
presentations of this panel which is
called titled inner colonization
development projects in the national
frontiers and it addresses the
relationship between modern architecture
and planning and the undertaking of
governmental II sponsor development
project in the peripheries of national
borders the choice of the term
colonization with all its historical
baggage is obviously not incidental its
vast array of associations including
population management and social
engineering spatial yerkes such as core
and periphery or urban segregation the
role of modern architecture and planning
played in the jit amazing acts of
expansion as well as the complicated
dependency of national liberation on
modernization served as a very recent
and sometimes even concurrent historical
backdrop for the period and the
discussion that's the rehearsal of
similar processes within the national
boundaries by both so-called progressive
and conservative governments in the race
for Madison ization cannot be separated
from colonial practices and the notions
of development inherited from them and
yet the geopolitics of the Cold War and
its emerging powers introduce new
factors that change the stakes for some
extent i don't know maybe we have to
explore this proposition thus it is
important to raise the question to what
extent the inherited practices from the
colonial period actually changed or not
and to what extent the internal
colonization in each state was affected
by this new world order against my
against my any attempt to attempt
monolithic formulations the speakers in
this panel are far from presenting a
universe
approach towards the role and function
of modernist architecture within these
development schemes I will now present
the speakers and their projects Malloy
Quezada Perez an associate professor at
the university of seville will discuss
how modern architecture served Franco's
regime in finding a delicate balance
between between traditional and
tradition and modernization in the
design of new villages for purposes of
nationalist propaganda his son no akito
an associate professor at Kyoto Woman's
University will talk about the
involvement of architecting the rural
development project in Japan designed to
resettle returning colonial immigrants
and to maximize food maximize food
production and the architect role in
promoting and negotiation negotiating
welfare ideals of standard of living in
believe and she'll get lil adjunct
professor at sapir College in Tel Aviv
University will discuss the changing
concepts in the design of neighborhoods
within a developing urban landscape of a
desert region in Israel and the way they
manifest different approaches towards a
simulation of immigrants and finally
palliative Alice a PhD candidate at the
Center for Research architecture Gault
meets the University of London will
discuss the infrastructure control
mechanisms of the military regime in
Brazil over the Amazon territory while
expanding the category of modern
architecture to include multiple
administrative participants please join
me in welcoming our first speaker Manuel
quezada police thank you first of all
I'd like to thank Columbia University
and of course Martha Maria and
holla for this I think very interesting
and very useful conference I'm my my
presentation is going to be around it's
going to deal with the new villages
built under the Franco regime which is
from the 19 started in the nineteen
thirty-nine this project of new villages
even before the war was ended and ended
a couple of years before the regime
General Franco died so the radium died
with him so it's like the whole history
of the regime in a small story the story
of this small villages so it's not a
very important story in the history of a
Spanish architecture which is not the
leading force of the history of the
world architecture it's just a small
story but I think it can illustrate the
relationship between between ideology
and architecture so I will okay this is
a little experiment that the title is
wrong actually this Dutch shouldn't be
here and it should be new village it in
oldest fashion Frankenstein
in 1952 the film en bonita mr. Marshall
was a scream for the first time in this
film the director Louis Katia van langa
tells the story of how a spanish village
the garden real is made ready to receive
a message from los Americanos the
Americans visit which would be
accompanied by hangers and riches to
better receive their benefactors the
village decided to build up a set in
front of their own houses to embellish
the village and make it look more
picturesque more involution more
authentic the arrival of the cottage of
motorcars rounds great expectations and
the locals congregated in the main
square dressed up intrumental costume
the Americans in dirt earth when sprayed
us there fast cars leaving only a cloud
of dust the film was a straightforward
comedy about the reality of the Spain
the film also reflected your frustration
of autarky the failure and absurdity of
the rhetoric of the regime count report
we're doing is an absurdity at all in a
bulletin the Indonesian style was
precisely with the instituto nacional de
colony faviana national institute for
inland colonization had been going for
many years demanded by a fascist
rhetoric of the exultation of the rural
which was increasingly in images we
instituto nacional de colony 50 on the
I&C was in charge with the agrarian
transformation through irrigation this
work affected all levels of planning
from land use infrastructures or urban
planning to house in or strict furniture
irrigation required new workers next to
the land and since old villages were
usually too far away new villages had to
be built in order to house the newcomers
the so-called Galanos the architecture
service of the Institute was charged
with the responsibility for assigning
the villages the individual buildings on
the house him
the agrarian transformation was one of
the key subjects of Franco is propaganda
the regime displayed the new abundance
sociated with reservoirs Crocs and
villages as a continuing achievement
without forgetting the eternal values of
the race hence the Institute was
positioned within a difficult
ideological framework which extolled
tradition at the same time that it is
hired a form of modernity that was
unachievable during the auto key the
work of the agricultural engineers was
understood to be linked to their own
technological autonomy therefore the
tradition modernity dilemma was
transferred to the architecture service
and it proved a very controversial point
from designs with a military sense of
order to others with sense of tradition
and eventually to new trends into
modernity the first point of reference
for modernization throughout the West
after the Second World War was the Pax
Americana and its individual system of
values simulation cared not as a direct
mimesis but brother by a fortunate
encounter between a Spanish culture
which was beginning to abandon the
reference to tradition and a Western
culture which filtered by the North
American Empire tried to revive some
values from this abandoned tradition
following the Republican surrender in
this punished civil war the vectors
comprised an unabashed heterogeneous
block real power was in the hands of the
large industrial financial and land
earnings groups ideologies beyond these
economic interests formed the classes of
service among those ideologists national
catholicism stands out spanish
combination of fascism and religion
forged by jose antonio primo de rivera
founder of the fascist group of felan ke
before the civil war and dirt in that
war but despite this apparent
ideological primacy in terms of real
policy there was a progressive
distancing from the ideology of national
catholicism for economic reasons in
order to facilitate official approval of
the american brand of the Western world
this shift which had as its first point
of connection a common anti-communist
front promoted a technocracy
increasingly disconnected from fascism
the group worst-hit within the regime by
this new direction was precisely that of
the fastest phalange
the regime's frame of reference on
agricultural policy was the discourse of
primo de Rivera on the agricultural
problem the thinking of primo de Rivera
on the subject followed the 25-point of
the nsdap the Nazi Party in Germany
primo de Rivera championed rational
planning of resources which depended on
economic reorganization of a spanish
land from that starting point the units
of cultivation needed to be defined into
two types family irrigated small
holdings and Union large dry land states
and once the inhabitable and cultivable
area and the economic unit of
cultivation has been established as
primo de Rivera said the population of
his pain must be installed recently and
must be installed revolutionary
after the Civil War the Franco regime
used the agrarian ideal more as a weapon
for propaganda than as a basis for
economic transformation the countryside
was exalted the side of the patriotic
values which had made the country into
great Empire whose achievements the
regime was trying to readd it but what
was paradoxical about this exultation of
the small farmer is that it had a
fundamentally anti countryside policy
indeed from the first moment of the
regime the fundamental objective of its
economic policy was industrialization
this economic transformation demanded an
important mechanism of capital
accumulation and transfer of profits
from the agricultural sector to the
industrial world
that demanded a more profitable
aquaculture that despite the official
rhetoric did not give priority to the
family unit or the union unit but to the
large estate owners soon this
ideological shift was to arrive to the
I&C drawing boards the first purely
Fallon gist initiatives for Lance
transformation came from the architect
big door doors doors presented a model
of colony units consistent with a
jeweled form of Family and Union
production to these end Victor doors
established colony units from the house
to the village to the city and each of
these colonial units had at least
certain minimal resources for example if
the religious requirement for Harris was
an altar for a hamlet was church the use
that was made of these units depended on
each specific case of the ultimate
extremes scattered housing was most
suitable for irrigated land whilst on
dry land estates the population would
have to group themselves in a colony
unit of a hamlet or even a village
although the carne unit theory of Victor
doors was consistent with Fallon gist
thought it was not without you culture
altec knology for example the size of
the parcel of farmland an act hair
even with the best irrigated Lance was
not sufficient for the maintenance of a
family of 10 moreover the territorial
organization of his colony units follow
no serious principle of land planning
control and planning of the land was in
the hands of engineers who among other
points of reference drew on the
experience of the Tennessee Valley
Authority Tennessee Valley also involved
the triumph of hydraulic technology a
model that Spain wanted to implement
from the United States the Institute
learned irrigation systems the leveling
on the distribution of land but it also
gained something even more important
machinery and loans
the Institute also learned from the
mistakes of the North American
experience in choosing its settlement
models the preferred model in the United
States have been parcel of land with its
isolated house in but a 1947 study had
shown how the adoption of grouped models
was more economical but there was
another reason why this specific form of
settlement of the Tennessee Valley could
not be directly deported the
propagandist function of the iron see if
the modernization of technological
advances was being celebrated it was
tradition which appealed to the ordinary
man in his home and his village
and in debate about rural static
Ferrante and Victor doors would also be
defeated as he himself said in terms of
statics think of nothing more than a
military parade they distinguished
captain and the individual lieutenant in
front of the units are fine but the
soldiers imagine that there will be some
shorter and some taller Sam with their
rifles on the left and a blue cup others
with a red cup and a rifle on the ride
know when things are tired without
living space there is an equality of
conditions which must be totally
standarized these were the words of big
doors however the architect in charge of
the architecture service toshiba miss
did not share his criteria Thomas had
the last word on any project decision
made general layout or the detail of
office aid the herd of the service had
an idea of what the typical village
should look like based on a superficial
knowledge of CJ & Unwin
this village inspired by the popular
architecture of each region seen from a
distance was like a large horizontal
mass from which only the church tower
stood out the main square was the
principal space and the generating focus
of the whole layout the road system was
laid out from already existing roads
better without square angles and from
their relationship with the plaza in
order to create perspectives that focus
on the individual buildings for
functional reasons the separation of
pedestrian and animal traffic was
promoted which was reflected both in the
road layout and the design of the houses
the block was understood as an
individual architectural element in
which corners elevations volume should
be resolved the hole provided are
restrained irregularity a simulacrum of
how villages had grown spontaneously
this picturesque affection was the
architectural version of deactivated
national Kafala system applied to the
countryside but its own limitation soon
became evident
in a few years the type defined by a
mess even with regional variations
demonstrated its shortcomings precisely
in the aspects that it had been trying
to avoid by making villages individual
all the villages ended up looking up the
same
from 1948 onwards the international
isolation of his pain began to be
relaxed that year the frontier with
France was opened in 1951 Spain joined
the World Health Organization and UNESCO
a year later in 1953 the agreement with
the United States on military bases was
signed accompanied by other agreements
on economic and technical support in
1955 admission to the UN was achieved it
was the end of the autarky in 1952 the
architect alejandro de la SOTA received
a commission the village of esquibel
near Seville within a few months he
presented a radical new design which
broke with the policy of the I NC a
layout like a fun open to the landscape
and using an interwoven but happen
disposition of streets for pedestrians
and traffic
the layout used at least two references
to anglo-american urbanism on the one
hand the closed diagram of her words
ideal city was reinterpreted in sotas
preliminary sketches on the other hand
the rappin block though inverted in
esquibel that is to say the desperate
traffic within and car traffic without
but without abandoning being till around
about which in the rappin block was used
for changing the direction of the cars
and in Esquibel was used for a meeting
space
more than the site burn the absolute
novelty of a bluffer opened to the main
road was a huge shot for the I&C but
thought on you how to use propaganda for
his own good he explained
all villages have very important part
this is usually the buffer which they
jealously hide in their interior when
passing by from the outside the village
presents itself with its back to us as a
rugby scrum where it is difficult to see
the heads of the players should we keep
these uncomfortable truths in the
villages that we create today it seems
not even less in those villages that due
to specific circumstances take upon
themselves certain obligations of an
exhibition nature of buganda unsought us
was a propaganda and an exhibition space
which adapted clearly modern
compositional devices for example the
main buildings of the bluffer the church
and the Town Hall were detached from the
continuous mass of the pass aid and
located at the focus of the ellipse
church and state took the form of
leading actors in a play whose backdrop
is a neutral and almost obstruct
architecture though inspired in popular
elements
head architect Xhosa Thomas was
horrified and the village was rejected
only to be passed by the very director
of the I&C of course was not the only I
NC architect in his work direct
influences from North American urbanism
appear the I NC villages themselves
could be understood within the framework
of the neighborhood unit in the manner
of Clarence Perry the I NC established a
number of obligatory elements church
town halls cool shops and so on even
when the size of these villages was
usually far from the 5,000 inhabitants
that Perry demanded another achievement
of North American Planning introduced in
composition of the iron say villages was
the Ratburn block intimately linked to
the rappin block the development of the
organizational possibilities of the
super block was a device also employed
by several architects who worked for the
I&C in Canada the Agora architect
Fernando del amo explored this road in
Sacramento architect firm and le tiran
made the theme his own at this time
inside the square geometry to the extent
of converting all the village into one
single super block the definition of the
village center was another subject
influenced by North American urbanism
and the core of the city movement in
yanos disodium coach Antonio Corrales
investigated the possibilities of the
open and closed in a project which was
at the same time public facility and
shadow space and construction
years later Fernandez Alba presented in
El Dorado a central forum in the style
of the modern revisions constructing a
true pedestrian heart that were
circulated to the rest of the village
another mutation taken to the bluffer in
particular of the small village was that
of converting it into a large communal
threatened ground in these cases the
dominant architecture was not so much
that of the institutions but rather the
houses which even within the
dictatorship could be reproduced triumph
of the citizen with respect to religious
or administrative power after the
American victory in the Second World War
Spanish official rhetoric followed the
fastest ideology of the Falange while
economic policy was directed towards the
capitalist transformation of the country
inside a broad us frame the village is
produced by the eye and see clearly
illustrate this ideological shift of
pranker ISM and the difficult
relationships between power ideology and
modernity the initial road of volante a
militaristic one but perhaps close to
some modernist assumptions was
repudiated and replaced by domesticated
recreation of the agrarian popular but
architects like sota Fernando del amo
Corrales or fernando de Toron would not
take long to merge in their own way the
tradition and a modern architectural
culture already integrated in the US
culture
while European democracies of the 1950s
were beginning to fertilize the dream of
modernity with a forgotten values of
tradition Spain's impoverished
dictatorship over a slept in that
tradition started a quick race to catch
up with what then seemed unen reachable
modality thank you very much
so it's my town good evening ladies and
gentlemen my name is a sneaky tell of
who is from Kyoto Japan before I start
my presentation I'd like to send great
thanks to the staff and professors of
this university inviting me to this
international symposium thank you very
much again today I'm going to introduce
a poder project in Japan I suppose you
may feel strange on my topic because
holder is the special role and in the
Netherland the Dutch society is called
older model in this presentation the
Dutch engineers prayed very important
law in making the folder in the 1950s in
Japan actually Japan is also a country
that had been making many folders in
modern time the Pope at the purpose of
reclamation project for agriculture
reclamation work for agriculture and
Boden industry in the rate modern type
the purpose of this paper is to
understand the laws of the Arctic to the
modern period project on the hatha yoga
folder in order to understand the
contributions of the Arctic we decided
to study how the issues on rural
development project planning which took
place during the decision-making process
where were dealt by those specialists we
then analyzed the following subject one
buckland of the product to how the
design process of this project was
developed three what kind of
architecture subject were considered for
the design process for how the modern
ideas was obsessed subsequently applied
to the Laura development plan by the
specialists so recently we have very
critical discussion on several folders
in Japan some project are discussed in
the code one folder brought big
environmental effort effect on the local
fishing the judge ordered the government
to in
the environmental condition of the area
my concern is contemporary development
projects not only in Japan but also in
the world producing food has been become
has become a very critical issue in
terms of environment population and ozzy
City Planning and so on thus the object
will be able to play important role in
order to support rule or planning we
decided to study the modern lulala
development project of the Haji Doggett
a folder in order to understand the
planning process we got running Lee both
articles in newspapers scientific papers
and literature on the project the size
of the hatchet all data folder is about
17,000 Hector this project is the
government's biggest declination project
in Japan this project started from 1952
and ended in 1977 during the 25 years of
construction works many kinds of
specialists were engaged in the project
this is a collaborative project in Japan
after the Second World War the
government aimed to achieve both a food
self-sufficiency system and encouraging
agriculture as a policy in order to
rebuild the society the government made
many all around development project such
as the TB a project in u.s. USA the
reclamation project was to be an all
around development project for Japan
that would provide the people both food
and jobs Prime Minister Yoshida try to
slow the problems on food employment by
using the reclamation project of a hot
yoga tub with the help of Dutch
government because Japanese government
hoped to recover friendship with the
Dutch government under the international
politics of the Cold War Prime Minister
Yoshida decided to regress the Dutch
government to
support for building the porter at that
time the Japanese are agriculture
engineers did not expect to learn lua
planning from the Netherland they were
just interested in the building method
of dyke the Dutch government introduced
professor Johnson who was teaching a tu
tu doubt he came to japan in april of
nineteen fifty four and conducted
research on the japanese folders and he
submitted the report to the japanese
government the lipid was very important
for the cut for the japanese government
to promote building the catalog data
folder the japanese government decided
to employ that consultation company
medical in march 1969 1956 on the other
hand the japanese techno club mr.
deguchi went to the Netherland in order
to study dike engineering he studied at
the TU Delft from nineteen fifty five to
nineteen fifty-six while mr. deguchi was
in the Netherland he introduced the
construction project of the East
prevalent folder in his article in Japan
mr. deguchi was interested in the dutch
design system of the folder he found
national and idea designing system in
which the landscape architects had an
independent bureau and they were
designing houses three paths and
agriculture field after this report the
Ministry of Agriculture we call my f
load Ministry of Agriculture and
Forestry Lord an article on establishing
the designing groups the MAF intended to
make a similar system to the Dutch
organization in the design process
professor ayka Takayama and many city
planners joined this project also the
MAF requested to study technical
subjects on branding the folder and the
new village to the city planning
institute of japan we call CPI J and
several
scientists institutions participated
with the planning process of the folder
the influence of the Dutch collaborative
folder method of Japan Japanese planning
system of folder is apparent the
electronic the clicker Lee clamation
project was discussed among the local
people and was a social issue in the
1950s the local people and government
were discussing whether the government
would conduct ali glam nation project
the foam of the folder was also a topic
in the discussion there were two types
of polder project one Porter was the
folder that has a small break in the
center of it here the other project was
to lay claim or areas of the lagoon so
this project was actually designed in
the beginning of 1920s and this project
was designed in 1940 the victory
cooperatives of the area was not in
favor of the Lee combination project
before professor Johnson proposed his
idea in 1955 there was no clear
direction whether the government would
conduct the project his idea was to make
one big folder in the middle of the
lagoon and to create a certain water
area of the lagoon he said himself that
his idea was compromised project from
two different types of the reclamation
project professor Johnson actually
criticized the common landscape of the
Japanese folders at the time he
discussed the monotone landscape on the
Japanese orders professor Johnson
recommended applying the natural contour
lines of the lagoon bed for the path
rain plan of alleble and his idea was to
make a good landscape for the people and
he lamented building a large Center
several sub centers
effective transportation transportation
systems he insisted on importance of a
living environment for its inhabitants
when the dutch and japanese experts were
working together for the polar project
an engineer who was in the Netherland
major preliminary plan for the border
mr. Eddie Caldwell made this plan in
Delft in December 1956 he plans one
central settlement and for smaller
settlement the former houses of the
farmer houses were gathered within these
five settlement on the folder the point
is that mr. holtville star suggested two
important point on the number of the
farmers houses in the settlement the
number should be a maintainable level
for landing the school and enough to be
suitable for collaborative agriculture
management he also recommended to
conduct socio graphic research for the
general plan of the Legion a modern
design method on the lulav running of
borders in the Netherland is singing in
his report the MAF made the original
plan which was the result of
collaborative work with Dutch
specialists the MAF intended to create
one unified region along the lateral
gotta lagoon where industries
transportation and educational systems
were to be integrated in one regional
plan we see the parcel in pattern on the
paddy field which are reflecting the
country lines of the lagoon bed the
technical of shells of the MAF a
variegated the comprehensive regional
plan of the note holder in the
Netherland in which both the old rural
area and the new polder were integrated
in one agricultural area the am we have
conducted an investigation of forms of
farmer villages in the Sean I brain
which had similar environmental
condition to the hetero gotta fold out
in order to make the general plan mr.
diggity who went to the Netherland
intended to make a social and economic
activity area and he proposed to local
public facilities the MAF emphasized the
concept of creating community on this
plan it was a big step that the
government paid attention to the living
environment of the farmers in 1960s
Prime Minister Ikeda proposed income
doubling plan this economic policy
played an important role in Lee
considering the agricultural management
program and settlement running the
specialists and the techno plots started
to discuss redesigning the project they
aim to restrain the income gap which
appear in the 1970s between workers in
the urbanized areas and farmers in rural
areas they decided to apply for higher
ability agriculture machine together
with agriculture management now you are
looking at very punny photo so the
farmer who is wearing white crosses like
a chemical scientist is working with
agriculture machine under this new
condition the CPI Jay made the tentative
plan in 1961 the CPI they proposed one
town and eight small settlement which
were composed of a link structure they
criticized the top operation of each
settlement should not be decided by
using the hypothesis of Agriculture
management the agriculture experts
proposed our community that would be
composed of 12 farmers for cultivating
each 60 hectare of paddy field the cpha
hepi they wish to make the rural
communities by using the concept of
educational condition at the time
professor EULA thought that the property
of farmers have been caused by the poor
who are condition of public facilities
this poor living conditions had to do
with the compulsion of farmers houses
which were scattered in rural areas he
lamented a settlement in which houses
stand closer together also the architect
paid attention to the composition of the
public facilities for younger children
and sick people the CPI J suggested the
new idea of making hierarchy focusing on
the living facilities instead instead of
agriculture production agriculture
production facilities the object
proposed lifestyle on the folder this
was named agriculture by commuting the
effect were going to bring the lifestyle
of the city to the lower area the Arctic
started to change the purpose of this
rural development project on the border
their object aimed to create a good
living environment for the people on
this folder through this project during
the year of 1961 the standard shape of
the arable land parceling patent was
decided because of the agriculture basic
law which was made in 1961 the CPI J
created a new plan in 1962 there were
the sun central town and there were
eight settlement adjusting to the size
of standard puzzling pattern of the
folder in order to make a general plan
professor Ishida collaborated with the
specialist of j/s ID are we who intended
to increase the number of immigrant
farmers because this agriculture
management size was more realistic than
the plan that was proposed by the MAF
the jas ID re was going to show a
solution
against the loo allele problems of
Agriculture management at that time the
scientists of jas ID re followed the
idea of making a good living environment
on the border with the collaborative
solutions among the specialists in the
design process on the other hand a
larger scale agriculture management by
employing bigger agriculture machines
was also in discussion when we use
maximum capacity of Agriculture machine
the total number of the farmers would be
about 1,000 and hundred the architect
were objects were against this plan
because it would be impossible who was
applied by a primary school secondary
school and hospital to be managed this
number of farmer families of one
settlement becomes a big issue in terms
of social welfare to build each
settlement would provide a good living
condition by public facilities but the
size of each parcel of arable land would
be five Hector the size of each parcel
might not make enough money for the
folder farmers while to make one
collective agriculture management unit
of 60 Hector by five farmer families
would not provide a good living
environment but the income of the
farmers might be higher under this
designing condition professor Ishida got
an idea he proposed to make one
settlement on the polder in june
nineteen sixty three without using the
eight site in the middle of 1960s the
local minutes parties were worried about
a gap that would appear for the
agricultural management between the
central folder and existing rural
village villages in the Legion then the
local Insperity insisted on the maximum
size of the Oliver brunt of the farm of
our families and in the central folder
should be five Hector on the other hand
some scientists said and technocrats in
on applying large agriculture management
the confrontation between idealists and
earliest can be seen the MAF and M web
we call Ministry of Finance were
negotiating in order to make the modern
bridge the MAF intended to small
intended to a small unit of Agriculture
management but M we have MF intended to
create a high level of living facilities
on the border adapting to a high level
of income policy but MAF did not agree
with the idea of MF the myf tried to
negotiate in order to avoid one
settlement plan we find that the
opinions of MAF were very realest
realest realistic but ideas of the
architect hired by the MF in order to
make the national budget in at the
prfecture the techno class of the
prefect technocrat of the prefecture the
mayors of the local vince parties and
the representatives of the agricultural
cooperative lead to the conclusion they
decided 7.5 hectare of distribution plan
we call for plates plan the MAF decided
in this run 1965 the MAF explained that
the prior primary school would be
managed and local temporary clinics
would be established and deed settlement
would be a neighborhood the national
budget for the polder bridge was summer
in 1956 9065 penza MAF started the
immigration program in 1966 the MAF
conducted research on the size of arable
land that the farmer would want to own
the result was that the average size but
9.6 hector that it may have estimated
that the total number of former families
on the central border would be about
1,000 then the MF
decided to make one village on the
border so now we are going to go to
concluding remarks dr. james also
spokesman who was a professor at Oxford
University loads that the japanese japan
is an unique country because social
welfare was introduced by the
Conservative Party actually the
Conservative Party has been making many
kinds of rural development project such
as a hot dog italic lamination project
in the late modern time the Technic lot
of MAF was not interested in the living
environment at the beginning of the
project but through the collaboration
with touch the Japanese engineer came to
an notice the importance of living
environment for rural development
project the techno club made a regional
branch aimed at creating a good living
environment as a part of all around
development project under the high
economic development development
situation the specialist started to
redesigning the general plan of the
folder because the income of form our
farmers should be increased create
increased catching up with the income of
modern industrial workers does the
large-scale agriculture management by
using big agriculture machine was called
for agriculture specialist aim to make a
higher performance of food production
the capacity of the agriculture machine
was going to be going to beat the
concept to make the community but our
text insisted on added on adequate
operation of the rural community on the
border in the in order to create a good
living environment through the public
facilities the architect insisted on the
criteria criterium size of settlement
and proposed sites was used for making
the settlement community the idea of
achieving a good living environment was
accepted by other specialists and the MF
adapted this idea for the making
our national budget we see the
contribution of the Modern architects
creating social welfare society through
this folder project taking over from the
idea of that beer the technocrat of MAF
the designing process of this powder
shows the modernity of making a good
living environment for the common people
and helps us to understand
transformation of the Japanese society
in the late modern time reaching toward
a social welfare state States so now
from this experience we are able to
discuss how artists could contribute to
the contribute to participate with the
rural development project in the future
thank you very much
good afternoon I would first like to
thank again Marta and Marie Ann I allow
for organizing this remarkable symposium
and having heard norms paper yesterday
and Vees in the previous session about
Israeli architecture I I do hope to make
one more contribution to this
fascinating period in Israeli
architecture the State of Israel
established in 1948 can generally be
viewed as one of the territories
relinquished by the British during the
post-world War two decolonization
process the new Jewish state consecrated
amidst a violent dispute with the Arab
Palestinian population initiated a vast
government directed development team
designed to construct new towns and
expand existing once conceiving planning
and architecture as key instruments in
the appropriation of the land within the
establishment of the state's hundreds
and thousands of jews immigrated from
diverse countries such as Morocco Poland
Romania Iraq and Argentina to name just
a few they were expected to become an
integrated society in Israel's melting
pot the term adopted for the vision of
Israeli cultural unification this paper
discusses the early planning and
architecture in the city of beer sheva
the largest in Israel's desert region
the Negev it examines two case studies
showing how the urban environment was
manipulated creating spatial hierarchies
that expressed socio cultural realities
born from national ideologies
concentrating upon the relationship
between planning and the absorption of
new Jewish immigrants it views
it against the marginalization of beer
sheva Muslim inhabitants the Bedouins
and locates it within the wider
discourse of modern architecture even
before the founding of Israel the Negev
region was absorbed into Zionist
divisions of progressive agricultural
and industrial development this vision
was officially adopted after 1948 as the
Negev became the locus of the ideal of
the conquest of the desert in Hebrew
kaboosh mama epitomized by Prime
Minister David ben-gurion founded in
1905 there Sheva was the only town
consecrated in Palestine by the Ottoman
Empire during its 400 year rule of the
region established so is the strength
and ottoman Authority in the face of
Bedouin tribal disputes and Egyptian
invasions the city was planned as a
modern western style grid of streets by
ottoman swiss and german engineers and
architects the british continued this
development she during their mandate in
Palestine which lasted between nineteen
seventeen and nineteen forty eight the
city's population comprised mostly
Muslim Bedouins and a small Jewish
community thus two consecutive
administration's the ottoman and the
british constructed their concept of a
modern city exercising control of
Bedouins and jews in a regulated western
urban space the development team
initiated following the establishment of
Israel was first and foremost a
government population dispersal plan
which success depended largely upon
settling waves of new Jewish immigrants
flowing into the country within this
policy approaches to planning bear Sheva
underwent constant reassessment and can
roughly be divided into two phases the
first between nineteen forty eight and
nineteen fifty-five during the initial
mass immigration
the second between 1956 and nineteen
sixty-five years when temporary periods
of decline in immigration enabled
reassessment of planning solutions in
conjunction with a developing
introspection of the social problems of
the melting pot between nineteen forty
eight and nineteen fifty-one architect
are you sure own designed a national
master plan for carrying out the
government's development strategy
certain aspects of which were discussed
earlier by Professor affront as you've
seen the Sharan plan included new
settlements and reconfigurations of
existing towns in the framework of which
very Sheva was also to be expanded
Sharon's plan revealed a marked
detachment of the expansion's
neighborhood unit cluster from the old
town and the latter was not designated
any function within the new urban
structure this phenomenon of segregating
new neighborhood units from an old
center conceived as oriental or a Moslem
entity existed in numerous and numerous
cities under colonial rule such as robot
or a year the separation of the new
neighborhood units from the old city
centers was done mostly due to racial
politics and fear of their subversive
other pneus despite the fact that the
old town of beer sheva was completely
deserted by its inhabitants when briefly
conquered by Egypt during the 1948 war
it still seems to have been perceived by
Israelis as Muslim foreign and
traditional in its urban makeup forming
and other pneus which was ambiguously
dealt with and did not fit into modern
town planning and architecture the mold
intended for the new Israeli society the
Muslim Bedouins were prevented from
returning to the old town which was
entirely appropriate
aided by the state so as to enable a
military and civic base for a Jewish
Center in the Negev the fact that their
Chevis temporary immigrant camps were
located south of the old city further
problematizes this issue the majority of
new immigrants placed there while
waiting for their permanent apartments
to be built were from Muslim countries
and were considered by the more
established European Jews as quote
primitive or oriental and other placed
as far away as possible from the new
neighborhood units the temporary camps
created an additional mode of
displacement in this case for Jewish
newcomers and now back to the
neighborhood cluster in the plan it
represents the first phase which was
based on creating a town out of
neighborhood units based on Garden City
ideals and probably the theories of
Patrick I Brackenbury the British town
planner these units would create
autonomous communities that would foster
personal relationships few roads and
abundant pedestrian walkways nestled
among parks were planned to create a
healthy environment for families
projecting socialist agrarian planning
into the town sharing and cooperation
were dictated by the nine private
exterior spaces outside the single flat
no distinction existed between lots and
the buildings faced public lungs chona
Aleph or neighborhood a was the first
bill with radial roads and expansive
open spaces planned by michael kuhn it
comprised flat and gabled roof buildings
with four apartments each with a hint of
discontent sharone described these
buildings as monotonous due to their
industrial mass production
adding that space is minimal and that
they're intended for future enlargement
diversification of dwellings was
impossible at this stage due to the
enormous time and budget limitations
that mass immigration posed the houses
were significantly smaller than what was
adequate for families especially those
arriving from Asia and North Africa
which usually had three children or more
in style and in-ground plans the
apartments of the first phase created
equal living spaces for all prescribing
the spatial functions of Western society
and by that declaring that the newcomers
were to be absorbed and unified in a
progressive Western culture in reality
as a result of the different cultural
needs of each diaspora the
neighborhood's developed according to
country of origin and the immigrants
tended to stick together to maintain
their religious and cultural customs
another serious drawback of this
planning was its unsuitability to desert
climate cheap materials lacking
insulation left these dwellings exposed
to the extremes of summer heat and
winter chill the planners wrongly
assumed that winters in the Negev were
mild this was after all a desert
furthermore the vision of a blooming
desert waned water was insufficient and
the expanses airspace between houses was
abandoned to dust storms and filth the
first neighborhoods were gradually
deserted by anyone who could afford to
leave with the remaining population
being of a lower socioeconomic level
these neighborhoods became the loci of
slums the first neighborhood units were
thus twice abandoned first by the vision
of the garden neighborhood and second by
the vision of concentrating within them
people from diverse diasporas who would
prosper in the socially advanced
public housing the second phase of
architectural experimentation commenced
circa nineteen fifty-six and was
accelerated toward 1960 probably also
due to changing ideas regarding the
methods of success successfully
executing the policy of the melting pot
a relative decrease in immigration rate
also allowed a higher building standard
and the construction of more spacious
apartments the most important project of
the second phase was chacune ledroit or
the model neighborhood constructed
between nineteen fifty-nine to 64 this
was the first serious attempt to
effectively plan a neighborhood tailored
to the desert climate it was an
experimental project with far-reaching
implications for the entire country as
it changed the approach to public
housing planning of the model
neighborhood was distributed among
several leading architectural firms with
the ascii and alexan droney leading the
project the neighborhood was unique due
to its extreme density intended to
minimize public gardening and provide
ample shade it comprised three squares
of flat roofed row houses framed by long
taller apartment blocks isolating the
neighborhood from the desert the grid of
row houses was nicknamed the carpet for
its regulated pattern that reminded one
of fabric the carpet had private patios
and its houses second levels protruded
toward the street creating covered
pedestrian walkways each of the carpets
was to have an adjacent Tower creating
several apartment types and a varied
urban landscape which was so lacking in
the block public housing of the first
phase the introduction of several
apartment types however stood in
contrast to the earlier constructs of
socialist equality of dwellings and
as we shall see expose social
stratification according to the
immigrants countries of origin the model
neighborhood was the result of research
into public housing conducted in 1957 by
ascii and his team for the purpose of
improving the new immigrants living
conditions yeah skis report concluded
that apartments should be planned
according to a quote the needs of the
average immigrant family end quote yet
added that they should be quote a vessel
for education for healthy family and
social life thus immigrants remained a
population that could be molded into the
new society other architectural debates
reiterated this quote we do not need to
build according to a person's living
habits we need to teach him how to live
in an apartment it is our obligation to
educate them and we need to determine
the apartment types and how they should
be lived in end quote so published
Israel's architecture and engineering
periodical this condescending approach
could only deepen the immigrants
feelings of exclusion and displacement
underscoring their alien nation from the
architectural process which continued to
be authoritative Lee formulated it is
interesting to compare the model
neighborhood to contemporary plans by
roll on soon a in French ruled Algiers
and I'm sure you'll be able also to see
the similarities to echo shared plans
for Casablanca that agile discussed
yesterday a model neighborhood planned
in a year in 1955 only two years before
the bear Sheva plans exhibited similar
dense grids framed by apartment blocks
the plans differed in that the bear
Sheva apartments at a very European
style ground plan while in the Algerian
one the French architects attempted to
accommodate local living customs this is
perhaps most
parent in the placement of the areas
traditionally allocated to women in
semanas plan the kitchen is tucked in
the back of the apartment and is
connected to an anterior loggia so as to
uphold modesty and provide extra space
for chores in the back in SLO Tovin
hopkins plan the kitchen is located near
the entrance and the patios are not
placed so as to accommodate housework
it's important to note that immigrants
coming to Israel from North Africa and
other Muslim countries adhere to living
customs similar to their Muslim
neighbors and would probably have been
more comfortable in a ground plan that
suited their traditional family life of
the long apartment blocks in bearsh
Eva's model neighborhood the most
interesting is the 250 meters long block
constructed by a ski and Aleksandra knee
conceived in the spirit of liqueur
Jose's 1952 city within apartment
building at the United a potassium and
Marseille it epitomized the exposed
concrete apartment block by horizontal
orientation the use of white triangular
supporting columns and a clear and
clearly defined concrete grid fast aid
likely aplicacion the quarter kilometer
block as it was called included spacious
two-story apartments the United efficacy
on also inspired yeah ski and alexandro
knees immigrants hostile bordering
bearsh Eva's old town which was an
upscale temporary dwelling for
immigrating professors from Europe whom
no one dared sent to the slum like
temporary immigrant camps in the south
of the town in both cases modernism
inspired by one of its greatest
advocates liqueur busia was chosen as
the appropriate module for connecting
new immigrants to the melting pot for
the Jews emigrating from Europe it would
show that Israel is by no means lagging
behind modern Western architecture to
the Asian
North African immigrants it relayed the
demands of absorption into a dominant
culture that defined itself by Western
standards displaying westernization to
third world societies through Lacroix
buzios ideals was not limited to Israel
alone and probably stems in part from
the Masters own plans for Algeria and
other developing countries Yassky had
indicated that the neighborhood's grid
had the same orientation as the old city
of birth Sheva in this the model
neighborhood was the first to relate to
it some historians have seen this as an
expression of an Israeli return to a
Middle Eastern vernacular that was
hailed in early Zionists architecture
which adopted regional or Orientalist
characteristics but then abandoned in
favor of modernism however it is my
opinion that the relationship between
this neighborhood and a regional
vernacular demands a deeper
investigation Yassky probably
rediscovered the relevance of the old
city because it actually remained the
business center of the town despite
attempts to establish one closer to the
new neighborhoods the fact that barajas
old Ottoman city was planned according
to a Western team also places this
assumption in question two additional
issues that I think require further
consideration in this context are at
first the concept of carpet
neighborhoods as derived from Islamic
cities and second the architectural
discourse in Israel during the 50s and
60s with regard to appropriation of
Islamic architecture in view of the
arab-israeli conflict the model
neighborhood reveals these complexities
the prejudices toward Jewish immigrants
from Muslim countries could suggest
correlations between the concept of the
old city as oriental with providing a
supposedly oriental carpet for new
immigrant
yet in reality the model neighborhood
was a high-class enterprise which drew
immigrants from Europe and South America
as well as veteran Israelis with only
seventeen percent of its population
immigrants from North Africa and Asia a
large number of which lived in the
smaller block apartments the problems of
the social gap between Western and
Eastern Jews were thus magnified by the
introduction of a new architectural
approach of using several apartment
types in the model neighborhood to
summarize this condensed look at birth
Sheva exemplifies architecture and town
planning as used by the state exercise
so as to mold both the desert and its
settlers this architecture was an
experiment in modernism constantly being
revised shifting from the vision of a
green and shady habitat to desert urban
landscapes architecture was constructed
to provide the physical space of a
homogeneous new society where diversity
was ideologically framed as a burden
rather than an asset contrary to policy
and planning these teams and they're
controlled allocation magnified rather
than diminished cultural distinctions
these neighborhoods which were both the
physical and discursive space of the
vision of the melting pot consequently
became the site of multiculturalism
thank
sorry
can hear me yeah so again thanks to mark
ahmadiyya and I ala for setting up the
seminar which was greater discussion and
and I guess my I am the last speaker
because my the title of my lecture is
called the last open frontier right so I
had to be putted at the fine of the
presentation I hope to be briefly
because I know that everyone is tired
and after hear the speakers of this
panel when we see the sort of like the
frontier of architecture being expanded
by the state or in a natural environment
in Japan or in agricultural lands in in
in span and the desert in Israel I hope
to to contribute through discussion but
I call my my paper the last frontier
because I'm looking at the Amazon
territory right and in a way the Amazon
territory is very much portrayed as as
the image as the signifier of nature
itself right I with few significant
rates of urbanization a subjective image
as that it comes to us as a vast Oh
maggiano's greenery had a sort of
generic green sort of like natural
environment inhabit most by by primitive
populations this is very much in my
point of view sort of like a colonial
image of the Amazon because since the
wake of the colonial expeditions reports
documentation about the region's natural
geography attempt to map out the the
potential profitability of the forest
resource for African economies is in
colonial periods in the Atlantic economy
and of correlated one as we will see so
this cartography is are in a way a sort
of cartography of an imagined and gold
land right a so-called search for the
Eldorado that had animated explorers
conquerors scientific expeditions
navigating upstream its reverb now I
think this
this conceptual the sort of like image
of nature itself has a more conceptual
connotation so far as it recalls us the
sort of construction of Western
ophthalmology if you want where nature
itself is very much understood as an
objectified as an object ready to be
exploited ready to be transformed and
ready to be manipulated in a way right
so I I think my job here is to demystify
so that such an assumption trying to
describe a landscape which is indeed
organize it and and or which appears in
a sort of process of urbanization and
moreover try to deconstruct the this
image of an object fight nature and and
that is to say try to give to the forest
itself or to nature itself a certain
type of political agency which I think
it's crucial to understand environmental
special act act organization today so in
order for me to distance myself on a
sort of colonial narrative I'd like to
borrow an image of a post-colonial
narrative if you want and describe it by
by one of one of the most important of
brazilian writers who navigated upstream
this river that we are seeing now which
the poulos River which is on the western
side of the Amazon and he went for a
diplomatic a cartographic expedition and
while navigating from the mouth of the
Palouse River and to its springs in the
highlands of the western amazon as many
previous colonial travelers he wrote a
sort of eloquent report alongside its
technical data that he had to provide
for the government right it's a sort of
meticulous portray of the of the
abundance of the forest landscape his
prosthetic sense was similar in contact
to the colonial narratives but radically
different intent embracing a republican
view with dreams of national co
the writer Euclid's da cunha his call
depicted a land left in oven abandonment
deprived of all the means which
configure I state of civilization a
territory victimized by its own
excessive natural exuberance as opposed
to the numerous reports which
exhaustively depicted a lost eden where
man and nature conjugated in harmony
without the corrupted traces of a
vicious society you know the very image
of the noble savage in a way that was
very much animated by by by by the
narratives of the Amazon their clits the
coefficient of ratios environment in
constant instability contrary to all
human efforts of inhibition so I'd like
to quote two phrases of a book that he
wrote which is called at the margins of
history when he sort of portraying the
Amazon so he writes the mass of water is
no doubt without comparison capable of
infringing terror so the image of the
kids that we know when he faced the
nature was it was an image of Terror
right and in relation to society what he
got what he encounters there it could be
described by this quotation there is no
law but only the legal codes of old
carbines and an uncountable number of
little battles when is more heavily
armed groups decimate entire tribes so
in title his his book with the title at
the margins of history to be at the
margins inhabiting the limiting standing
at the frontier standing at the border
that d naturalized the possibility of
imagining the evolutionary base of
historical time appears in his lyrical
descriptions not so much as the
reification of the Iroquois division
between primitives and civilized nature
and culture so peculiar of colonialism
to the contrary he consciously avoids
temporal linearity in order to describe
a territorial situation each being
contemporary to the present cannot be
assessed through the categories used to
depict social and natural landscape
elsewhere so in a way it sees a
territory outside history
reading right in that sense it's sort of
like frontier that I want to talk about
at the Amazon both nature and society I
on the verge of a total a
complementarity regulation being lawless
conflicts and in appearance of all
natural convulsions the closest possible
description resembling the topographic
inconsistency collective organization
like basic institutional political
economic frames that Taylor any ordinary
collective life there's perhaps no other
history to tell about the Amazon
frontier if you're not one explored
through the investigation of this
marginal condition of this condition of
being a frontier right providing we take
the full consequence of what this might
mean and step out the dualistic linear
frame defined by the colonial order
which very much depicts this is a sort
of like nature environment waiting to be
civilized and which depicts the sort of
population that leaf the inning as
primitive populations progressively
constituted as the erasure of the
material power and means of organization
of its traditional inhabitants the
Amazon frontier tells the history of the
constant seizure of indigenous lands
made by external forces often conjugate
international capital and the
benevolence of the nation state in the
names of the dubious process of the
development and modernization
supervision and personal of land
exclusion and denial of land rights its
possession and violence our story Kong
constants which are still present in
this region I have to say that history
is the one for each architecture and
urban organizational rarely had provided
infrastructural means and an ideological
framework so I'd like to start so
whatever you offer is some sort of like
snapshots or postcards of this of the
frontier of the expansion of the river
frontier and I'd like to start with a
short video
Gingka vs cd43 mahashiv she knew the ice
to the windmill it died without the
encino program hadn't told a is SE
progetto EG distance on that date
Amazonia photo via the chromosome
anything since Atlanta the boys are holy
cow rosa ave maria' a syllogism
regimentals mega project for harshness
years of argentina so beautifully
those that boys are rocking my clothes
you practice Awards camenisch top or a
bottom of the stone of a silver shoe
room
le7 design in coba dog food are woven
Brasilia Sylvia's this is all provide
electron watch tranquille the miracle of
the Podesta chance approaches the
difficulties he attend here as far as
New Year chester has in Jesus within
Jesus of Suburbia I need to hear Adams
asteroid Cucaracha also be here Lovato
large ella tambien salami for physically
shesh keep a sofa cama faster to help me
remove my property prepare tonight
producer you had an bravest so waves of
immigration to the Amazon start in 19th
century and the varying and
progressively the continued until being
intensified by the military regime in
the 60s you know any oscillates very
much according to variations in global
economy in relation to resource
extraction right so 19th century the
rubber bone in Europe and then you have
First World War the search for rubber
strategic supplies so it fostered
immigration internal HD amazon again
then in the 30s 52 de Vargas which we
have be seen here so many times project
of governmental at immigration which was
called the march to the west I start to
populate the territory and then in the
50s starting in parallel with the
process of design in Brasilia there is
the process of occupation in the Amazon
which as I said was going to be
intensified during the military regime
so Antonia which is a political activist
in the Amazon when I met her she's very
much one of the say one of the
testimonies witness of this process and
when she moved to the amazon she and the
military detector ship is implementing
this sort of territorial
network which is of course a process of
violent reorganization of ecological
political modes of being she get
involved with the pastor Oh Land
Commission which I'm not sure if you
know but it's a very famous sort of like
left-wing organization that merging
Latin American the 60s in reaction to
the military regimes that were happening
there in right and it's still very much
important as a movement organized being
working together if in indigenous and
prisons movements so the title of this
lecture could be against architecture in
a way because often these forms of
resistance and they would take forms of
struggles against implementation of
spatial infrastructures insofar as urban
infrastructure's or architecture they
mean the rear tickle a shin of
ecological political modes of being
right and here i want to emphasize that
politics here is very much in connection
to the way the environment is organized
itself so we cannot detach a social mode
of being to the way that these people
you know they they relate themselves to
nature so in a way the construction of
the dam for then means a threat to their
own mode of being in so far as the very
resource that you know sustain their
livelihood is going to be out in so far
as the DECA logical system is going to
be transformed and that means a sort of
like political social and at the end
Kootra reorganization of the off of
their modes of inhabitation so as a
group of matter of environmental concern
the amazon has appear in the date of
1989 this is not to say that as a fiscal
space a large path of Equatorial
tropical forest with a very large river
net center it has not been living in by
some notice by others colonizing
inhabited and Exploited before but what
I'm saying bye bye bye highlighted these
specific points that a concept or space
we came to recognize the Amazon as at
this precise for a point and as a
problem of geopolitical relation as a
global environmental
issue as a contemporary problem of
government as the site against which we
came to recognize ourselves I would say
our relation to make sure or relation to
the world around us has a particular
date in this East 1989 when the Amazon
frontier start to appear in the
international agenda right so 1989 is a
paradigmatic date you know you could say
because it's the very articulate of the
Communist hypotheses no way and some
would claim the very sort of victory of
capitalist and liberal democracies but
some could argue as well that is the
very crisis of of capitalist mode of
production so far as this this is the
time that the environmental crisis
coming into being right so by the time
that environmental crisis starts to
appear in the international media you
know as sort of of as an outcome of the
collage occur movement to the seventies
in the eights articulate in America very
much in Germany but by by 1989 the
Amazon frontier and actually this
conflict in a conflicting the western
side of the Amazon related to rubber
tappers it became sort of very a
paradigmatic offer or or off of the
introduction of the environmental issues
in in the international agenda so in a
way the crisis of the environmental
crisis and the conflict they are the
twofold a product of this sort of code
war economy laid out by the militaries
in the Amazon through this sort of the
developmental programs supported by
international institutions such that IMF
or I or the word back right so one hand
it is a crisis of an economic model of
development self em and I'm going to
come back to this but it's also a cries
of sort of political model namely the
cries of this developmental agenda that
reestablished the sort of colonial
contract at the second world war i would
like to quote for example Harry
come on in his first speech when he got
the presidency I'm not sure if it's the
first speech but when in presidency of
the United States he said we must embark
on a bold new program for making the
benefits of our scientific advance and
industrial progress available for the
improvement and growth of underdeveloped
areas the oding peril is exploitation
for foreign prophet has no place in our
plans what we envisage is a program of
development based on concepts of
democratic fair dealing while discarding
parallelism and colonization he
introduces a new form of contract
between industrialized north and
societies of the global south the idea
of development strangely enough as I
would stay the Creator has come into
being by the definition of this negative
the creation of developed is in fact the
creation of under development right
because underdeveloped is not something
to take for granted but effect was
something very produced historically and
this is sort of my claim here that we
have to deconstruct the idea of under
development harridan naming an already
existent phenomenon the post-war
discourse on development actually
created this so-called porter the world
and by its own turn the third world
itself in Brazil to the hands of the
military has embraced the idea without
further critical perspective aligned
politics with external demands foster
under the legitimacy of democratization
ironically however in Latin America
developmental Enterprise heavily
constituted a democratic process on the
contrary they were mainly carried out by
detector regimes often externally
designed as developmental programs
filtrated by local governments
development was in fact an extension of
Cold War politics articulating security
against the communist hypothesis at
international scale through the
enforcement of violent sovereignity
inside national boundaries of the south
I mean I think we had like clear
examples how this sort of developmental
agenda mainly directed to Latin America
which was a threat for for United States
directly during the Cold War is in fact
a sort of extension of cold war economy
to keep the sort of communist I protests
in in containment traditional modes of a
habitation low demographic density a
lack of infrastructure was seeing as
vulnerable points of the sovereign state
which had to be surpassed for the sake
of the constitution of a modern nation
locally development ideology was no
rarely applied by means of urban
organization whereby architecture would
serve as the magic for state policies
and governmental programs to act as
truly mechanism of control there were
just as efficient as the colonial
Imperial contract so my claim here is
that the development itself reenact in
certain ways the idea of the colonial
contract under the brand of development
the great projects designed by the by
the military detector shipping resile
function as a process of internal
colonization organizing the geographical
scale of the state through the
articulation of architecture and urban
roads as a frontier line of expansion
now when this conflict to be true the
environmental price was already let's
say laid out no so in 1972 is the first
conference or perhaps the significant
conference in lighted nations on the
human environment already
I'm totally laid so okay so I try to be
really fast about it so let's say in
1972 when this conference appears is the
it's what I call the conscience of the
disaster or the conscience of a sort of
like environmental catastrophe that that
came as a sort of global issue right and
starts to appear inside the
international politics indeed stock
should really find a certain sort of
political sensibility but at this time
you know the idea of the accident it
comes very much as a sort of democratic
accident in 1974 what is what is at
stake is that sort of like unbalance in
between nature and human insofar as
humanity inhabit a sort of single planet
right so you know the sort of ecological
crisis is going to be it's more or less
shared democratically so I'm going back
to this image so what is happening in
1989 which is like the earth to meet in
Rio 92 and that's why like the Amazon
was very much at stake at this point is
that the environment itself become a
question of social justice ie that
environmental price or or or the sort of
like deregulation of the environment is
not shared with humanity itself but in
fact is very much localized situated and
this imply a mode of violence right so
this is in a way what is interesting for
me is that this is a sort of reenactment
of the colonial encounter if you want to
read like this but what is different in
that image is that who called for the
encounter was not let's say they
colonize itself but was the very
subjects of polarization so they
organized themselves they set up a table
and the invite they state to have a
conversation with them and then that
means for me that the arena of
international politics is being
redefined I'm doing a sort of like
healthy
argument right something that has no
part in the political arena now it
starts to to to to shape and redefine
the political arena and that is when the
sort of like environmental sensibility
is coming about United Nations and in
several levels of government so let's
say I would tell i think the so i'm
going run very fast with this this is a
map of the digital map of a general go
body as you see he designs in 1957 he
designed the brazilian territory with
several connections and the amazon
appears as an island to be connected
right so this is the process the the
project of territorial design as i claim
all this sort of yellow poles are
disposed of development in which one of
these nodes are organizing through means
of urban infrastructure's and now i
don't have time to go for this in amer
so i'm just going to show you some image
of the so these three exclusive this is
this is one of the off of the modernist
in clubs in the amazon which is at this
point in the north of the basil it's a
city designed by one of the very famous
and modernist architects so there is a
sort of like a rifle division he is the
bureaucratic personnel and he is the
workers this is a mining a logistical
node as you can see the sort of
geographic oh there's the road and then
the city and usually the road open up
paths for for deforestation and here is
the city right so you have the the road
and that connection to the city and he
is the mining area this is another
project the diary project which was a
platform built in japan and installed in
the north and shivered through the ocean
in stein the north of
of of the Amazon again two cities have
to be designed to provide a sort of
logistical and personnel for for this
agenda of development this is an image
of the trans amazonica I had a video to
show but I don't have time so a world
away this another city which is a el
Dorados garages as you can see again
another node and the idea of the
exploitation of the Amazon and idea that
urban organization is necessary to carry
out this developmental agenda this is an
image of the city okay so i'm just going
to conclude i totally miscalculated this
presentation and actually you know I
it's really much shorter than it was at
the beginning but still too long so this
article trace it back some key points
although you couldn't see it perfectly
but next time of some of the key points
of this often violent in length history
of occupation of the Amazon offering
snapshots of urban and architectural
dimension postcards of the most
pragmatic examples of development of the
urban frontier in the Amazon territory
can highlight the failure of the social
economical ecologic politics that
characterized the ologies of development
and therefore we suggest can also inform
the creation life yet to come spatial
patterns of environmental political
organization arguably the infrastructure
lay down by the military's during the
60s and 70s where the basic means of the
impressive process of destruction of
natural resource in the Amazon basin
that alarmed the world in the late 80s
although environmentally friendly Shin
allottees have since then entered into
the official political agenda via Earth
sumeet and the sort of United Nations
led environmental programs notions of
development still opera dying in the
process of in habitation of the Amazon
in third world spatial realities in
general as you as as these lines are
returned the Amazon frontier continues
expanding bring along the same old
stories of violent and possession
recently I don't know if you have been
following just after the crisis there
was major conflicts in the frontier
between Peru because of oil extraction
as well as a process of land grabbing in
Africa you know after the crisis
everyone more or less went back again to
to land as or trying to secure land
because the sort of environmental crisis
there it's going to happen so you have
to secure territory in a way to predict
your your your job political role so
that is my favorite thank you very much
thank you very much for your wonderful
papers and I appreciate this most of you
also brought this to the present you
also started with the debate in the
court happening nowadays and and in the
shift from the global perspective that
you took us to I would like to return
back to the question of the relationship
between the nation and the state from a
very particular angle that all of your
presentations refer to your
presentations address different forms of
transnational movement of knowledge and
expertise applied within the territorial
borders of the state in this the
architect took the role of operating as
balancing mechanisms between the global
and the national technological
advancement in the tradition just to
name a few movements in the double move
of incorporating the frontier into the
national territory while integrity
integrity heterogeneous population into
a unified image of national cohesion I
would like then to address the question
of the relation between the state and
the national territory and the image of
a coherent national body by means of the
case that it's you presented in other
words how these new communities because
to even in the franchise regime I guess
the they were considered this new
communities because they had two became
assimilated within the whole and also in
your case you didn't mention this in
this paper but the case was of a new
immigrants and coming from yes of Japan
so they had to reintegrate it into the
society by this isolated new villages
and so how this new communities became
assimilated within the whole or better
said the demonic Center and in turn how
their presence permeated into
the center or becoming a part of the
edgy moaning and affected if it's all
the conception of the nation so if we
look at it conceptually it's the
relationship between the periphery which
in this case is geographical and the
National hedging money which is the
center but here it's incorporated within
the center especially in the case of
propaganda so let's see if I can sort of
think about these questions you asked in
the first place I'm not sure that I
complete when I speak about state and
nation is going to be the same in Spain
now we've got this debate of a state
which is a nation of nations and it
would be a very long story a story won't
go in in there but just to warn you that
my concept of nation might might not be
the same that you have then first
question how these communities
integrated with the rest well it I think
depends on the actual economical process
if these new villages were located near
a CD for example near severe for example
near a place were years afterwards the
bubble the building bubble would affect
these communities then they would be
integrated they would grow in a way they
would be destroyed as well buy this
building this must building with lived
in Spain in the last 10 years probably
here geographically integrated you mean
territorially integrate they would be
territorially they would be socially
integrated because other the villages
that are far from this centers from far
from this building centers all
economical sense
they have a little by little being they
have disappeared there are hardly nobody
leaves there anymore but then this
should not be seen as a failure of this
experience as much as if you think that
when they decide these villages they
knew this would happen why because the
size of ability in Japan you've talked
about the size of the village and what
would be the best size for the and the
different criteria in Spain the criteria
was the criteria that you should live
near the place you would the land you
would work and that meant since in the
work there were no cars in the 1940s 50s
on beginning of the system 60s that
meant that you could only live one hour
and a half away by donkey so that meant
that the size of the village should be
reduced that meant in our tradition that
this villages would probably not be very
successful after the years but they knew
that but that was the only thing they
could do or that's the only thing they
thought they could do the criteria was
similar to Italia Italian criterias at
the time as well so in that way they
knew what would happen so when you mean
by minted as a means of propaganda and
modernization you actually mean what
modernization is facade kind of like to
be a flat no no no I mean no or maybe
i'm mixing concept i mean if there was
no industry to support well there was
our agriculture I mean these villages
were meant were built for agriculture
and they work well when there was there
were no cars as soon as cars appeared
people went to the nearest big village
that had nothing to do with if it was
only for say
it if it was wholly propaganda I focused
on the propaganda issue here because I
thought it was interesting but it would
be more complex than just what I believe
I imagine you saying I think just the
question whether there was an actual
industry in those cities over there were
very small villages those just industry
to repair the the camera to just all too
there was no industry it was like maybe
200 families 100 our family so they were
very very solid industry was not if you
go into regional planning than the work
there are certain experiments or certain
in tiny black haired blonde by the heart
which is a whole province with industry
with dumb with the water infrastructures
with these villages that's a whole
complex another situation but mainly
this villages were just build for
agriculture so there was no industry but
I don't think you have to judge this
industries by whether there was like
these villages were the work those
industry around or not I think that
that's not the point with this villages
or with what they were trying to do with
the villages
well with regard to to my case study of
their Sheva I mean I think that that the
question of Natan agen and frontier has
a lot of you know theoretical premises
that we should probably look here at
that historical moment and I would say
that that for at least the way I
perceive it for the cultural act of
nation building I think we see in
various histories that especially when
you have this ideology of a new society
that it needs to be framed and in this
sense I think we can perhaps visualize
the situation as as the the frontier or
the border being the the frame whereas
the the new immigrants were conceived
sort of as the the content or the the
center of what is to be this this
perception of nation but also in this
case and I know I'm address that briefly
yesterday in the discussion I think that
the whole concept of of settling a
frontier has biblical connections
because when Jews come to settle Israel
they perceive it as a resettlement and a
continuation of the biblical era and and
the the the text that they refer to when
constructing this this narrative our
text that really keep configuring
borders and the notion of frontier so as
to you know settling the desert and
going to promised land etc so i think
that here especially the the question
that you raised is
because it's sort of based on a very
ancient narrative that in itself i think
really stressed this whole concept of
geography as as something that really
defines a nation I was actually if we
talked about your case very it's very
obvious that i'm referring to them to
the incorporating of the Orient yes
within the contours of the modern
nation-state yes then the puzzling
question of how to incorporate them
accommodating them and at the same time
modernize them and the question this
also came out from no arms paper was how
actually the State of Israel has changed
through this absorption and the ideas
and the ideals of the state or it's a
European homogenic base has completely
lost its ground yes well I think even in
this I think some some of the narratives
that we see still make make this
connection of of Jews coming from Muslim
countries as something that just just as
the Muslims and the Palestinians were
conceived especially in the beginning as
something that Rafe eyes the Bible and
any ancient traditions but but there's
one more point which which I think needs
to be said regarding how it affects the
state and this is the political point
which which which I think we need to
remember that there are even in this
situation where new immigrants are
coming there are multiple sort of
contestations regarding how to deal with
this whole concept of absorption and I
think that that there's one narrative
which is the government's
and I think they wanted to appropriate
them just you know for the sake of of
their own political ends and then there
are the voices that that stress
different opinions because again as we
stated earlier the frontier is something
which is constantly being revised and
constantly being negotiated and so
obviously from this whole process the
since the immigrants themselves i mean
the eastern immigrants and mozilla the
immigrants from Muslim countries
eventually contested this whole this
whole project it of course eventually
had very big influences on the nation
and the concept of nation and this is
what I was referring to at the very end
end of my talk that these actually
became the sites of multiculturalism and
diversity as a total opposition I think
to what the original idea was when there
was this division of everyone becoming
sort of one homogeneous society and a
small question was the carpet model
incorporated in other places in Israel
yes it was we have later examples in
karmiel and a-rod and in various other
places without connection to climb it at
all oh yeah yeah sure I mean a-rod's is
another city in the desert but come here
come here yeah yeah yeah so yeah it
certainly had its vogue in places which
are not necessarily a turd okay so then
I talked about national frontier in
1950s so maybe I would like to explain
so many background and also yeah at the
time to make a folder is regarded as a
very peaceful way peaceful way to get it
with a land because Japan embedded her
asian countries also after the
a third world war we made a very
peaceful constitution and then also the
in the Netherland that's also used the
significance of making a folder but to
make a land by peaceful message so the
place government hired that idea problem
Netherland maybe this is also kind of a
frontier because Japanese government
show oh there let's say we are going to
establish a new state that is going to
make a piece and also yeah but on the
other hand the Finnish government need
money in order to develop national
frontiers and at the time after a maybe
maybe you do you have any idea of the
Japanese island we have a coke idol
island at the nose of the plane for
island but actually so world man the
world won the World Bank one man burbank
try to invest money in order to college
bait the hook kind of area and also the
hasta la gata project was also targeted
by the world bank but unfortunately or
fortunately i don't know but actually
the modulo gotta project reject to use
the money from the International
Foundation and then so this means from a
very interesting article in the
newspaper the reporter said that when we
don't use the International money we are
able to do what we want to do we don't
care anything about business since so
that maybe I think yeah I'm feeling that
for the hospital data project japanese
attic and the city planner and also
agriculture eight year were be free to
do anything also they could achieve
their dream without concerning business
on agriculture and in terms of the
architecture itself you didn't you
discuss the standard for this
architecture or for the for the planning
of the region for the neighborhood yes
how about the architecture itself that
is a very modern modern is my idea
because when we think about the less a
contradiction between the Ministry of
Agriculture and Forestry and object
Ministry of Agriculture and Forestry try
to make original plan but when we think
about the more welfare society in the
folder so just just the object focus on
focusing on the only the folder to make
a more perfect welfare society excluding
the surrounding rural areas that was a
very point and also that was very let's
say modern is an idea and what kind of
effect it had on you
actually at the beginning of the project
the hottie regatta project try to invite
the people from former colonial
countries but but actually the industry
in that relation of the society I
started at the same time a friend had to
look at a project to start it and then
the the people who the mystery of
Agriculture expected when do have a nice
areas and finally so the mystery of
Agriculture and Forestry hard to look
for the people who could come into the
folder yeah because construction to the
building process is very long and and
also at the same time the social changes
very quickly and this is a point to see
this project today would you say that
it's a successful project except for the
fishermen ah yeah so this is a very big
yeah that's a very the point to discuss
about this project but actually on the
other hand so deafening society is kind
of a very so negotiated society and yeah
let's say fisherman's yeah of course
some fishermen continued the fishing but
most of the fishermen got the land in
the folder but not only the new
immigrant but also they got jail and so
it's a kind of making on balance maybe
this was controlled by the politicians
in relation to can you hear me
relationship the nation is they think
like the first assumption bit nation is
not a state right any status or a nation
so it's important to make this like
distinction whereas you know what my
understandin nation is immoral sort of
gutrot social idea organic concept with
of course embody a certain ways of
political beings whether they stated
sort of I would say you know roughly an
artificial construct which in fact
organized nations as in the name of the
state right as as a mode of power which
you know work that survey capture
machine in several nations in a way so
the idea of a nation state in my point
of view is a very dangerous one which
often in history has led to good Rome
homogenization ethnic cuisine asking
about how this project in that frontier
that we're trying to incorporate the
frontier yeah it's economics within the
nation-state in what way you're not I'm
going to get into this you know but just
to talk about the nation-state because
it came it came yesterday as well if i'm
not wrong the ideas i think it's
important what we are discussing state
it's important to discuss that's why i'm
asking about the relationship between
those two yeah exactly so so in a way
that's what I'm you know that's I think
that that's my point for example you
know I think Manuel is totally writing
his point are talking about the
different nations inside a single state
for example in the Amazon you have the
animal nation they are a donation the
kaya pollination all ready to get inside
a single state and over hold up just for
me to finish and and and in the project
of the state in itself the project of
the military regime is in itself make a
one single nation right a nation state
which is which was a violent project
right so and if you look for example
what's happening now in Bolivia which is
led by an indigenous president now they
change their name to the pleura nation
of Republic of Bolivia ie it means that
the state of Bolivia has incorporated
and
a sort of political voice to the several
nations that is inhabiting bolivia in
this process they call the
decolonization of the state so i don't
know if that you know it's if it answers
your question right but but but but
that's what I what I think it's
important to acknowledge in the relation
between the state and nation just know
to add another degree of complexity in
Spain we're not talking about as a state
of Nations but a nation of Nations which
is a little bit more complicated and has
other reasons for that and this one
thing I wanted to share with all of you
and all of you that is from all the
papers that we have earth today I
couldn't come yesterday but I guess it's
more or less the same or better no I
mean well but it is that this there's
always this question I asked my students
and it's a question it's not a rhetoric
question because I don't really know the
answer and it is what can we learn from
history and more how can we learn from
history and then this is a very interest
in symposium for that question mainly
for architects now I think this
situation is very different from done of
the 1940s 270 not only because of this
state but because of the architect as
well so I just want to share this to all
of you ok thank you for this concluding
remark and but we still have time for
one more question
thank you this question is directed to
single consolidated because it seems to
encapsulate in a strange kind of way
your presentation we can thank the
Franco regime for fitting within the
confines practically of 1940 to 1970 in
a very peculiar way but in fact the
notion of internal colonization in Spain
goes way back it goes back as very
identified with the Borbon regime
there's a famous instance of pablo de
olavide a in la lucia you know to
colonize areas that have been deed this
inhabited because of the forced
migration of the muslims and other
groups and also the economic decay of
the country but more recent times i'd
like to put to you a question that in a
sense such as opponent was just
discussed which is that for instance if
you look at the 1929 international
exposition in Barcelona which everyone
of course knows because of me Zander
rose famous pavilion you forget that
just a few steps away was an exhibit
that still exists that was known as a
polo spaniel now knows the poble
espanyol Catalan which is an exhibit
which recurs his typical architecture
from throughout Spain which in the
period was an important movement know
there was side by side the process of
creating a modern language there's also
a compilation of vernacular architecture
typology know and of course just before
the Civil War during the Civil War you
have that the Ministry of in the lessee
operator who was very important
socialist minister he occupied i think
the ministery of fomento he was very
responsible for many development schemes
and has been said that his development
schemes in fact were taken up by the
fascist regime violet that curious
intermediary of the Fulani which was
typical of fascist regimes had a lot of
rhetoric from socialists but the
important thing is they carry over in a
program that is a program not of the
fact of Franco regime but a program of
the State Building regime of Spain and
during the period of the civil war
itself you have important compra viv
moments in the collectivization of the
countries
especially in the region of Catalunya
under the anarchist movement which were
in effect the same purpose
recolonization the countryside make it
more effective keep people that works
based on all of that now all of this to
my question which is this obvious that
there is a a program that's associated
with nation-building with the state
which somehow which I find I have many
triple difficulties with which is
confusing this notion somehow it's a
progressive thing but it opens itself up
to a lot of flavors hey I'd like to ask
you banned perhaps others could reflect
on it in verse of their particular
regions and how has this nation building
perspective been taken up how does for
instance the program under the Franco
regime compare with the program of
collective eyes in the countryside
Catalunya which very nationalist has its
own national agenda headed in a civil
war as it today how does it compare you
know because one has the objective but
also what has the identifiable selection
criteria of effectiveness on the part of
the planners same in any different
ideology as to what has been achieved
what is to be achieved for building the
state you know which is a transnational
ie global a notion that is being imposed
everywhere but which has always a
conflict between the actual reality of
what that place is that's my question ok
it's now again like almost everything
it's even more complex than what you say
because this is a very rare experience
in Spanish history because it's in like
in how many years have 40 years we had
very different regimes we had the
cellular democratic but it was not
democratic of the restore affion
afterwards we have we had a mild
dictatorship primo de Rivera not this
pretty mother a better the other
Primavera very Miguel p mother waited a
dictator afterwards we have the Republic
and afterwards we have Franco but this
idea of not exactly modernity but pro
through the irrigation started in the
19th century and was part of the probe
of the program of all these different
regimes and each different regime wanted
to implement to build this progress
through irrigation in its own way Franco
was the only one who managed to do it
because he stayed in powerful almost 40
years and had a complete had complete
power and that he he managed to do it
very unsuccessfully actually in terms of
economical transformation but then when
we go to your question I think you
shouldn't be asking to for example the
comparison with the Catalan experience
because there's one much better
experience to compare it with that is in
the Republic it's very clear during the
republic government we had the reform
Agraria which was like to those who work
the land managed to own in some way the
land but then there was another very
interesting experience that was the open
the obviously waste time Diego which
meant to transform three relation the
poor lands of for example and anthea
mainly civilian cordova and and through
this kind of villages actually they had
the same agenda they had the same
program and actually those engineers who
work for the Republic for the day after
afterwards worked a flat for Franco and
actually one of the ministry of
ministers of Franco works for the
Republic and before works for the
primavera later and before worked for
the restoration so it's as complex as
that and so what's the main difference
the main difference is not in in the in
form in how it was built at the
architectural form that was different of
course because the period was changing
but it was
to whom it was addressed this
transformation Franco transformed used
it as propaganda but mainly used it as a
means of economical transformation that
would benefit the landowners and well
that happens today as well these land
owners had big estates and that meant
that the transformation could be more
rational that's the same policy that the
you in the European Union follows now
today that it to give more power and
give more money to the big estates were
us the Republic address the oldies
transformation to the poor peasants and
the poor workers and that's very clear
it would be maybe it too long to tell
now but if you compare the amount of
land that was given to peasants during
the Franco and the amount amount of land
that was transformed almost for free to
the land owners and if you compare that
to what happened in the Republic during
the Republic years well the
transformation via the experience is
completely different but the technical
thought even that this the engineers and
many people who works for the Republic
afterwards works for Franco because we
at least in Spain we don't have to
forget that architects were there were
some social socialist architects but
Assam as a group we were privileged
class somebody who could study
architecture was usually from high class
and that made it very easy to go from
one not you know not only on time I at
all times but for example in these
experience it is very clear that those
who worked for the Republic were the
ones who were working for the Franco
regime thing I've how they answered your
question
we have to go have a roundtable
discussion upstairs which I hope people
will be able to speak I can't already
and so I invite you all there's gonna be
also reception over there I'd like to
invite you all to just bring the
discussion upstairs over a glass of wine
that yes I can wear lungs